[Musique]
bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct pour ce débat de la
matinale dernier france bonjour on va
parler de l'actualité du moment ont déjà
avec ce post vaccinale qui entre en
vigueur ce matin en france alors que le
représentant de l' oms on l'a vu en
europe juge plausible la fin de la
pandémie grâce aux variants omicron fall
écoute fallait-il maintenir cette
obligation de passes vaccinale selon
vous gilles penel
on voit bien que le calendrier de
monsieur macron concernant le post
vaccinales et les éventuelles
améliorations qu'il pourrait y avoir fx
est en relation directe avec son
calendrier électoral donc cette
situation est désormais absolument
intenable on nous a fait croire que
pendant plusieurs jours mais en
plusieurs semaines au moment des fêtes
de noël que la situation allait être
catastrophique on avait déjà des indices
particulièrement important venant de
grande-bretagne sa vie que ce vernis au
micron dont sept étaient certes
contagieux mais pas dangereux qu'à un
moment donné le nombre de contaminations
diminuerait c'est ainsi donc là on y de
fait croire qu'on va desserrer
les restrictions dc1 fin février le 13
le 13 pour les escales de lévriers pour
favoriser voilà comme un sauveur la
candidat la candidature d'emmanuel mâcon
tout ça n'est pas sérieux on joue avec
la liberté des français on joue aussi
avec la vie des français depuis deux ans
maintenant ce gouvernement raconte
n'importe quoi ils ont très clairement
pour des imbéciles soit par incompétence
soit par amateurisme et maintenant par
intérêt électoral donc il s'agit en fait
désormais d'être particulièrement ferme
et de démontrer à emmanuel macron et aux
français bien sûr c'est un peu sur elle
doit cesser
ils voient les français méritent
aujourd'hui bien mieux qu'à un
gouvernement qui cherche impérativement
à soigner
sa campagne électorale et ainsi
favoriser l'entrée en campagne du manuel
desserrement des restrictions je précise
ce sera le 16 février pour les
discothèques
les rassemblements les concerts
notamment debout maxence briquet selon
vous est-ce que le gouvernement aurait
dû desserrer l'étau avant
alors non seulement il dut desserrer
l'étau avant mais il n'aurait pas dû
proposer des mesures aussi absurdes
telles que le port du masque en
extérieur par exemple le fait de devoir
prendre ses cafés n'ont pas de boom est
assis donc on est sûr on nage en
absurdie on va dire on avait des mesures
absurdes celle que j'aime vous énoncez
qui vont être blessé par une autre
mesure absurde qui est le pass vaccinale
qui n'a aucune utilité à toulon le dit
la communauté scientifique le dit c'est
un but qui est encore une fois purement
politique emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
capitalise sur sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire qui est au demeurant
calamiteuse mais qui lui sert à masquer
un bilan qui encore plus calamiteux pour
le coup en matière de politique
étrangère en matière d'immigration
d'insécurité de souveraineté tout est à
revoir chez emmanuel macron et
l'avantagé cette crise sanitaire pour
lui c'est qu'il n'est absolument pas à
rendre de comptes aux français ils se
cachent derrière une peur qu'il
entretient en permanence et pour nous
c'est important de dénoncer ça et
surtout de dire qu'aujourd'hui on n'est
plus dans une phase où on fait de
l'amateurisme on a besoin d'une gestion
à long terme de l'épidémie comme local
maladie qui va rester endémique et avec
lesquels il faudra vivre ses skis avec
zemmour propose alors hier le
porte-parole du gouvernement a assuré
également que les dates de lever les
restrictions notamment cette réouverture
des discothèques serait maintenue
écouter gabriela talent
les dates seront tenus tout cela est
évidemment liée au pass vaccinale qui va
entrer en vigueur lundi on a des raisons
d'être optimistes avec la décrue net du
variant dalta un début de baisse en
réanimation et une décrue depuis une
dizaine de jours du barrio omicron dans
les régions où il est arrivé la position
du gouvernement c'est de n'être ni
rassure east ni en ferme east mais
d'être réaliste art ni rassuré ni en
ferme east mai mais réaliste c'est le
cas gilles penel c'est un peu le triple
en même temps là ça bon voilà on a
l'impression que le portant le
gouvernement arrive ainsi en sauveur
pour sauver la santé des français tout
ça n'est pas bien sérieux si on nous
explique que désormais le vernis au
micron comme c'est une certitude
maintenant est en train de diminuer
manca supprimés diamant le pass
vaccinale le pass vaccinale n'a pas
raison d'être on nous a fait croire en
fait pendant plusieurs je me répète
pendant plusieurs jours en plusieurs
semaines que la situation était
particulièrement grave ma supprimant
désormais puisqu'elle ne l'est plus le
pass vaccinale qui est une contrainte
absolue notamment pour les plus jeunes
parlent pas suffisamment des jeunes
pendant pendant cette crise on va
demander avec un enfant de 13 ans pour
pouvoir aller à un entraînement de
football pour pouvoir aller au cinéma
impasse d'accident
mais on a bien compris que avec le
gouvernement ont tenté en permanence on
nous faisait croire que ce n'était pas
pour le vaccin n'était pas pour les 12
16 ans nous a fait croire que le vaccin
n'était pas pour les 5 12 ans puis
finalement on s'est trouvé à faire
tester des enfants de cinq ou six ans
une véritable torture pendant les fêtes
de fin d'année en direction de dizaines
de milliers de jeunes tout ça est assez
insupportable maintenant parlons
effectivement des vrais sujets parlons
du pouvoir d'achat parlons de
l'augmentation spectaculaire du prix de
l'essence parlons de l'augmentation du
prix des lexiques de l'électricité parle
d'immigration parlant d'insécurité bien
sûr parlons de tous les sujets puisque
emmanuel macron va pouvoir ainsi
distillé en fait son petit calendrier
jusqu'au 2 mois d'avril prochain non il
y aura des débats macro participent à
ces débats qui sont majeures pour la
société française de demain le
gouvernement dès qu'il n'est pas en
ferme east maxence briquet qu'en est il
de ces cinq millions de français qui
n'ont pas de passes vaccinale ce matin
le gouvernement en fait fait fait un
mauvais choix parce que il est évident
que le vaccin est une arme qui est
extrêmement utile contre la pandémie
mais il faut aussi voir ses limites
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on a très
bien vu que ça fonctionnait très bien
pour limiter les formes graves pour les
personnes fragiles mais que au niveau de
la contamination ça n'empêchait pas
grand chose même si c'est à des effets
enfin le la comité scientifique est
d'accord là dessus mais ça reste quand
même assez minime comparé au bénéfice
pour les personnes à risque donc
aujourd'hui nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est
que ce soit les personnes à risque
qu'ils soient ciblées this way qui se
vaccinent qu'ils fassent leur troisième
dose et que derrière on rend dans une
gestion à long terme avec avec des
traitements il y en a pas mal qui ont
été aujourd'hui homologué par l'agencé
européenne de sûreté sanitaire
vous avez aussi le fait de prendre des
mesures qui sont beaucoup plus
structurelle le fait de remettre de
l'argent dans l'hôpital mails mâcon n'a
pas cessé de fermer des lits pendant
toute la pandémie ce qui est un scandale
d'ailleurs coûte beaucoup trop cher et
que cet argent devrait le réinjecter
dans les hôpitaux
bas pour le coup je pense que les tests
font partie d'une de la stratégie que le
gouvernement devrait adopter et ils
l'ont complètement abandonné sous
prétexte que ça coûte trop cher et
surtout pour inciter les gens à se faire
vacciner aujourd'hui si aimé moi demain
jeudi enfin moi je veux accéder mais
quelqu'un qui n'est pas vacciné qui fait
un test moins de 24 heures avant d'aller
au restaurant aura beaucoup moins de
chance de le porter que moi donc de
contaminer quelqu'un donc le passé
actional en fin de facto n'a aucun
intérêt contre la contamination on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation 90% la
population française vaccinée vous avez
aujourd'hui une tension hospitalière
dont le nombre de personnes en
réanimation qui est quand même parce que
parce que c'était au début de la
pandémie en mars 2020 donc il faut
savoir raison garder il faut se rendre
compte que tout le dur tout ce qui est
fait partie du la nouveauté de la
pandémie est derrière nous aujourd'hui
on la connaît cette pandémie et qu'il va
falloir apprendre à vivre avec on
dénonce forcément toutes ces mesures de
privation de liberté qui sont
aujourd'hui complètement inutile alors
on va passer à d'autres sujets au
pouvoir d'achat notamment gilles penel
vous nous en parler on va parler de
sécurité également mais emmanuel macron
est en forte baisse dans le dernier
sondage ifop 37% d'opinions favorables
on le voit à l'écran c'est une baisse
inédite de quatre points en un mois
comment est-ce que vous l'expliqué
gilles penel
et emmanuel macron prendre
progressivement dans le dur dans la
campagne électorale il semblait
effectivement perché sur sa colline las
ils sont les réalités et à les français
comprennent bien et vont le faire savoir
qu'il n'a absolument pas résolu les
problèmes qu'il avait lui-même soulevé
il ya quelques années la situation du
pouvoir d'achat et probablement pour les
français on l'a vu ce matin je projette
dans un récent sondage proposé par
france inter est de loin la priorité
absolue des français est absolument
anormal anormal que des classes
populaires des classes moyennes nous
voulons voir se priver la possibilité de
terminer leur mois parce qu'il va
falloir rajouter 10 15 20 30 euros pour
leurs prix les pour le prix de l'essence
pour le prix de la facture énergétique
tout ceci est une est une réelle et ça
saute aux yeux des manuels macron et je
lui je pense que dans les jours et les
semaines prochaines par entrer
véritablement effectivement dans le
difficile et sa cote de popularité va
cesser de
continuer à diminuer et nous serons
l'alternative c'est une chance
absolument extraordinaire celle que nous
proposons avec marie le pen de pouvoir
battre enfin mais elle m'a compte est de
trouver une véritable alternative à sa
politique à sa politique néfaste
notamment en direction des classes
moyennes et les classes populaires
justement pour le pouvoir d'achat
maxence briques et eric zemmour a fait
des propositions
ça va être véritablement l'enjeu des
débats à venir selon vous
le pouvoir d'achat comme d'autres sujets
a oui le pouvoir d'achat et est placé en
préoccupation numéro un des français
dans tous les sondages une grande
majorité des sondages qui sont de leurs
préoccupations il y en a évidemment bien
d'autres l'insécurité l'immigration la
souveraineté l'éducation fine a
énormément et l'eczéma propositions sur
tous ces sujets là mais je pense qu'il
est important de rester pragmatique
lorsqu'on parle par exemple d'un cas
très concrets qui est l'augmentation du
prix des énergies et notamment de
l'essence et l'électricité
on est face à une situation où lorsqu'on
prend par exemple le cas de l'essence il
est important que les entreprises
prennent leur part dans cette histoire
eric zemmour oppose aujourd'hui que les
entreprises remboursent à 50 % les frais
de carburant propre les personnes voilà
vous aurez quand même
véritablement je vais vous dire
je
m'en sois triste et même sur une mesure
un artisan non il faudrait
va vous donner la parole vous pourrez
réagir juste après maxence vous
inquiétez pas monsieur je comptais
parler de ce que vous proposez parce que
c'est complètement absurde aussi ne vous
inquiétez pas aujourd'hui les
entreprises
historiquement parlant l'entreprise
lorsqu'on prend les usines par exemple
dans les années 1830 1840 les
entreprises loger les ouvriers sur place
parce que l'entreprise prenait sa part
dans l'histoire elle se disait qu'il
était important que l'ouvrier et des
bonnes conditions pour travailler
aujourd'hui vous avez pour les
entreprises le versement mobilité qui a
bon dos le budget des collectivités
territoriales qui sert à financer les
infrastructures de transports pour que
les gens puissent se déplacer à l'eau
travaille aujourd'hui pour la voiture on
n'a aucune compensation pour les gens
qui n'ont pas accès aux infrastructures
de transport donc c'est une mesure
pouvoir d'achat qui est très forte pour
l'église et pour eric zemmour je le
rappelle qu'il veut quand même qui veut
baisser les impôts de production de 50
milliards qui veut des taxes et toutes
les premières embauches qui veut faire
en sorte que les petits patrons n'est
pas à payer d'impôt sur les sociétés
vous êtes bien mignon de dire à chaque
fois où ils regardèrent exhiberont n'est
pas l'ami de société c'est madame le pen
qui aujourd'hui fait du socialisme je
vais pas vous mentir monsieur lorsqu'on
voit ces propositions absurdes sur les
cartes sur les carburants typiquement le
fait de baisser la tva alors pour le
coup
c'est l'essence vrai que si vous le
voulez bien gilles penel vannes on va
nous répondre ce qu'on doit juste de
seconde le fait que la baisse de la tva
justement ça fasse en sorte que le prix
des énergies repose sur l'état que les
l'état encore une fois devoir mettre la
main à la poche pour des problèmes de
fluctuations de cours du pétrole qui ne
sont pas inhérents à ce s que l'état
peut prendre en charge et donc c'est
encore une fois une vision extrêmement
étatiste de marine le pen pour qui
l'état doit faire absolument tout les
entreprises n'ont pas leur part
apprendre et l'eczéma ou encore une fois
ne fait que des des mesures pour
permettre aux entreprises d'être plus
flexible donc c'est une mesure absurde
cette mesure de remboursement est à
compensant certaines entreprises le font
déjà à leur niveau au gpl réaction non
il est clair que il faut baisser
interactivement les taxes pour rendre
directement l'argent en français savait
que sur un prix sur le prix laisse sur
le puits laissant 60 % sont des taxes
absolument anormal nous proposons donc
avec marie le pen nous le disons depuis
plusieurs plusieurs mois désormais qu'il
faut baisser immédiatement les taxes de
20 à 500 il faut rendre tout de suite
l'argent aux français le système
improbable que propose eric zemmour est
bien les artisans qui vous écoute
monsieur les petits patrons qui ont deux
ou trois employés ou qui vivent tout
seul et bien sont déjà écrasés par les
charges écrasés par les charges en fête
voulue et souhaitée notamment par heller
qui vous fait aujourd'hui un pont un
conte d'argent vous tout cela n'est pas
sérieux nous sommes directement en
direction des français des classes
populaires d'ailleurs vous savez marie
le pen la candidate de ces classes
populaires la candidate ancêtres de tous
les français nous ne parlons pas nous
monsieur a un petit peuple de droits qui
ne s'agit pas de sauver un petit un
petit cartel en fait de droite il s'agit
de parler à l'ensemble des français
notamment il s'agit de parler à ceux qui
vivent loin des métropoles à ce qu'ils
vivent ses villages ses petites communes
et qui sont directement frappés par la
hausse de ses prix absolument
inadmissible à qui on a expliqué qu'il
fallait acheter de voiture parfois 3 et
qui aujourd'hui sont confrontés à deux
plein fouet directement à ses hôtes à
ses hôtes spectaculaire des prix les
sens nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
parler directement en français et leur
donner immédiatement la possibilité de
pouvoir tout simplement revivre
décemment à la fin du mois il s'agit
encore une fois peu de temps je voulais
qu'on aborde quand même le week end
marqué par le le mythe no grand meeting
à cannes d'eric zemmour on a appris que
gilbert collard l'eurodéputé du
rassemblement national a rejoint les
rangs de la reconquête après jérôme
rivière est ce que c'est un coup dur
pour le rassemblement national gilles
penel je souhaite bon courage et
l'équipe d'eric zemmour qui vient de
récupérer gilbert collard j'aurais
presque envie de dire bon débarras à ce
mercenaire de la vie politique et
médiatique il avait disparu des écrans
de rassemblement national depuis
plusieurs mois je rappelle qu'il avait
été élu au parlement européen où il ne
siégeait pas d'ailleurs et il a trouvé
un petit peu de lumière il a son petit
quart d'heure médiatique bon c'est ainsi
voilà bon courage encore une fois à
l'équipe à l'équipe d'eric zemmour qui
récupère c'est iconoclaste encore une
fois de la vie et de la vie politique je
sens que je demande simplement à gilbert
collard s'il avait un petit peu
d'honneur il démissionnerait du poste
qu'il a occupé inutilement d'ailleurs au
parlement européen rappelle qu'il a été
élu grâce
dans quelques jours on ne parlera plus
de gilbert collard vous savez on sait
qui intéresse les français au moins on
l'a vu un seul essai leurs
problématiques ans est de la vie
quotidienne alors ses vicissitudes de
transfert ou de ralliement comme on les
appelle c'est pas c'est pas très
important mais j'imagine que jérôme
rivière doit doit aussi démissionné du
coup votre référent maxence briquet
vous en réjouissez évidemment
évidemment mais la réaction du rationnel
me fait doucement rire c'est à dire que
on a des gens qui s'ils vous m'aviez
posé la question il ya cinq jours qu'on
a vu ce débat s'arrêter l'encensement de
gilbert collard qui aurait été un
collègue essence pour la fondation du
parti était donc vraiment ces retours de
monde mais cela ne nous intéresse pas
gilbert collard est quelqu'un qui aime
plus sa patrie que son parti aujourd'hui
son parti son ancien parti le
rassemblement national est un parti qui
est en perdition on le voit bien avec
les photos qui avaient été publiés sur
twitter par david rachline et d'autres
avec le mot fidélité et marine le pen à
côté on sent bien que derrière ça il ya
une peur de voir les gens les anciens
militants duration nationale nous
rejoindre ce qui est déjà comme
massivement le cas avec d'autres
suivront parce qu'on voit bien d'autres
c'est jean marion maréchal par exemple
il est trop tôt pour évoquer un nom dans
tous les cas je vais pas en parler ici
mais d'autres suivront ça je peux vous
l'assurer et ces gens là étaient là
monsieur il était là lorsque lorsque
marine le pen a fait un débat désastreux
lorsque marine le pen a retourné sa
veste sur l'euro sur l'europe
aujourd'hui récemment sur la suppression
de la double nationalité ces jours là
était là lorsque vous avez eu votre
débâcle aux régionales ces gens là
étaient là aujourd'hui veulent plus
perdre monsieur en fait ces gens là
veulent que leur cité gagné
japonais
il peut être
l'occasion gagné deux fois elle n'a
jamais gagné
on voit en fait que l'autre forme dans
les sondages monsieur vous allez vous
commencer votre chute vous avez pris le
petit toboggan pour bébés en fait vous
allez descendre décembre et on voit en
fait dans toutes les instituts de
sondage quand il s'agite espère eric
zemmour au second tour il est écrasé par
emmanuel bach -70% sa brutalité son
manque d'empathie vis-à-vis des classes
populaires vous savez moi j'ai un enfant
handicapé et j'ai été profondément
marquées touché par les propos brut
inadmissible ans est de ceux polynice
qui considèrent en fait qu'il est sur un
terrain médiatique il ne veut pas
rassembler les français il leur a semblé
en fait sa petite famille politique il
propose des postes en fait vous savez
votre votre parti politique tout jeune
arrivée est en train de se transformer
en auberge espagnole où vous avez tous
les icônes au cassoulet mercenaires en
fait de la vie politique tout ce qui en
fait son deuil le sdf qui en fait c'est
un parler un parti de girouette ben je
vous souhaite encore une fois bon
courage nous nous sommes à quelques
encablures ans celle de la réussite les
sondages le disent nous sommes à 46 47 %
se vend pour votre candidat n a
rassemblé à peine 30% vous font les
responsables semblent et rassembler la
droite avec valérie pécresse rappelle
encore une fois que votre problème car
on peut lui dire ça avec tarik qu'il
était prêt à accueillir valérie pécresse
et monsieur xavier bertrand au sein d'un
gouvernement emmené par eric zemmour ou
tout ça ne nous intéresse pas allez ça
nous intéresse c'est de rassembler
l'ensemble des patriotes l'ensemble des
français mais pour un grand projet celui
de marine le pen donc eric zemmour je
vendre des livres eric zemmour propose
des postes et les amours on va proposer
avec monsieur bolloré de l'argent
gilbert collard de large sur
le salon j'ai serré pour nous il nous
reste quelques minutes maxence briquet
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas élever le
débat de seconde classe histoire
d'argent avec amour et d'ailleurs ont du
personnel c'est l'arrêté
d'emménager en plein délire avec votre
histoire de de dire qu'on est un parti
de
d'apparatchiks et c'est justement le
projet d'eric zemmour cette fois on est
un artiste fils et toute la droite dont
la droite qui va de l air hors assemblée
nationale la différence avec vous c'est
que nous ne sommes pas sectaires nous ne
crachons pas dans le dos de ceux qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec et quand vous
avez gilbert collard qui quittent leur
assemblée nationale de bonne foi parce
qu'il a très bien vivre
et qui sait très bien que dans tous les
cas ce que ce parti est une espèce
d'être d'astre mort qui n'a que marine
le pen est une espèce de cliquer secteur
à sa tête avec des militants qui sont
bien deux pions depuis longtemps au
courant que ce parti ne tourne plus que
vous n'avez aucune chance de gagner et
c'est aucune chance de gagner vient d'
une raison très simple c'est que marine
le pen ne veut pas gagner marine le pen
marine mouvement vous laisser répondre
mais sa réponse maxence mari mais vous
avez des jets votre casion de second
tour mais chez vous l'avez ratée avec un
débat lamentable et vous avez du jour
retournez votre veste sur le bronze vous
ne voulez plus sortir de l'ombre bien
sûr
trois minutes 66 même temps on vous
comprend pas du tout donc laisser finir
maxence briques et je vous donne la
parole monsieur connell avez passez
votre temps à retournez votre veste
toutes ces dernières années vous n'avez
pas arrêté de changer d'avis parce que
vous n'avez pas de ligne vous vous
cherchez un électorat mais la vérité
c'est classé des classes populaires
aujourd'hui vote pour eric zemmour que
je lis le connaissez est
confirmée ça reste encore à confirmer
évidemment le vox de sas populaire
gilles penel
oui merci merci monsieur lambrecq votre
candidat à peine deux minutes en 2
minutes 30 s'assagit le boulot devant
les caméras de télévision il était
déstabilisé par deux questions alors
vous savez les leçons de morale je
souhaite un jour peut-être eric zemmour
de faire un vrai débat devant à un
cador politique et on verra qu'il sera
bien ridicule qui ne sera pas devant ça
donc
il est temps que lui de versailles et
des classes populaires on peut ainsi
rigoler eric zemmour n'est pas connue
dans la rivalité et leeds effet ce n'est
pas comme dans les petites communes de
france on va voir si c'est pas
malheureux on n'a plus le temps on voit
que évidemment cette question fait débat
un débat peut-être fratricides à venir
en tout cas on voit que ça suscite
beaucoup de réactions de votre part
merci beaucoup on poursuivra cela
évidemment lors de prochaines matinale
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat